apparemment il nous prend en photo aussi
donc ça doit pouvoir marcher
comment
ils ne voient pas et pourtant il n'y a
pris l'écran photos - vale pour voir en
photo son public après tout aléa les i
s'ils voulaient faire une photo de
monsieur le maire on vous laisse une
minute
et pas beaucoup plus
est-ce que nous sommes certains qu il
nous entend
c'est bon
à
un problème technique
merci aux journalistes la merci à vous
mon problème technique
mais ça me
je
connais
[Musique]
bien est ce que est ce que cela
fonctionne
le destin
ok les scouts
bonjour monsieur le maire
merci d'avoir répondu à l'invitation de
nous deux commissions du sénat
et et permettez moi de vous dire
avec le président la faune et je crois à
l'ensemble des parlementaires qui sont
présents cet après midi que nous
regrettons les circonstances dans
lesquelles nos amis britanniques
leurs familles
ont été rapidement la situation dans
laquelle ils se sont retrouvés à
l'occasion de la finale de la ligue des
champions à quel point les événements
ont pu gâcher le plaisir qu'ils avaient
incontestablement de venir participer à
un événement sportif
nous vous recevons en votre qualité
d'élu britannique bien évidemment de mer
mais d'abord en votre qualité de témoin
des événements et en tant que supporters
de football puisque nous croyons savoir
que vous assister régulièrement aux
matchs de liverpool
je me souviens des temps anciens pour
moi d'un certain kevin keegan qui jouait
très bien et pour lequel le football
français a beaucoup subi
du fait de ces de sa qualité de
footballeur exceptionnelles
et vous êtes aussi en mesure surtout de
comparer les organisations et les
ressentis à l'occasion de l'ensemble de
cfoot de ses matches vous êtes exprimés
dans la presse
et sur les réseaux sociaux en indiquant
que vous aviez vous même été victime de
vol au cours de cette soirée
sur tous ces éléments nous attendons
votre témoignage
je dois indiquer également fin nous
devons indiquer également que depuis le
28 mai dernier
la police française a mis en place un
formulaire de dépôt de plainte sur le
site de l'ambassade de france afin de
permettre la poursuite de ceux qui ont
commis des infractions
peut-être l'avez-vous lu une question et
si vous l'avez lu qu'en pensez vous en
tous les cas quelles suggestions
pourriez vous nous faire mais avant tout
nous souhaitons monsieur le maire vous
entendre sur les événements et les faits
tels que vous les avez vécu merci à vous
en tous les cas d'être rendue disponible
cet après midi
donc inutilement un
bonjour merci de m'avoir invité
ce qui se
je vais continuer en anglais maintenant
merci monsieur le président je crois que
vous montrez un peu votre âge avec la
référence à kevin keegan
en ce qui concerne les événements
[Musique]
je vous donne je vais vous en donner des
détails
et en ce qui concerne le formulaire dont
vous parlez que les fans de liverpool
devrait remplir c'est de remplir c'est
un formulaire
n'est pas en fait
un formulaire de plainte
contre le traitement de la police lui
même et pour moi c'est l'une des plus
grandes injustices
alors que c'est c'est l'un des plus
grands mots qu'ils ont souffert
alors par contre devant muller et c'est
bien sûr de saisir des informations
mais ce qui est important c'est de
savoir ce qui commençait informations
seront traitées une fois qu'elles auront
été collectées
en tout cas moi je jette un oeil à ce
formulaire j'ai le remplirait
mais je comprends aussi que ces
formulaires doivent être envoyées par la
poste en france
lorsqu'il serait probablement beaucoup
plus facile d'avoir un formulaire en
ligne
et qui permet aussi un véritable suivi
des plaintes qui sont
envoyées
qu'en tout cas les fans bien sûr sont
contents qu'il y ait cet engagement de
la part des autorités françaises
mais il ya toutefois des doutes quant à
l'utilisation des données qui sont des
informations qui sont transmises et de
la méthode de collecte de ces données
merci de ce
premier message pouvez-vous maintenant
nous nous dire ce que vous avez vécu le
soir de ce match
kenza
lit
donc ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la nuit précédente est aussi
le jour du match j'étais à paris
et les parisiens étaient très
accueillants il nous faisait sentir
comme si on était chez nous
je crois d'ailleurs de nombreux
parisiens souhaitaient que liverpool
gagne
puisque real madrid avait gagné contre
paris dans le match précédent
donc il y avait vraiment un soutien fort
pour liverpool
mais lorsque je suis sortie du métro
pour me rendre vers le stade de france
j'ai vraiment vu un constaté un
changement d'atmosphère
et donc une journée de rêve s'est
transformé progressivement en cauchemar
on m'avait prévenu qu'il y avait des
groupes de pickpockets qui était bien
organisée
[Musique]
et malheureusement j'en ai été victime
en nous
mais ce n'était pas la chose à perdre
même si bien sûr c'était et
immédiatement c'était quelque chose de
difficile à vivre de 2,2 me faire voler
il a été ensuite difficile de comprendre
comment je pouvais agir parce que
j'avais en main volé mes papiers on m'a
volé mes cartes mon téléphone mon billet
d'entrée donc vraiment ma préoccupation
immédiate était grande d'avoir mis que
faire
mais cela n'est vraiment pas grand chose
lorsque vous comparez à d'autres
témoignages
de deux personnes qui ont été victimes
de vols beaucoup plus violent
et donc je pense que la journée tout ce
qui a précédé le jeu c'était vraiment
fantastique
mais
l'organisation autour du stade
et puis l'attitude de la police a très
rapidement transformé ces belles
journées en une journée négatif
monsieur r d'abord je voudrais joindre
bien sûr aux propos de me joindre aux
propos du président buffet sur pour vous
exprimer les regrets par rapport à ce
qui aurait dû être un dû être pardon un
bel événement de sport et qui
malheureusement s'est traduit par des
faits et des débordements que nul ne
peut accepter et dont un grand nombre de
supporters de liverpool ont été victimes
et vous dire comme l'a dit le président
buffet en se remémorant des exploits de
kevin keegan que nous sommes nombreux en
france a apprécié ce beau club de
liverpool est et si pour ma part c'est
pas qu'ils gagnent que j'ai en mémoire
ces dalglish mais il n'empêche que vous
voyez que liverpool est ancré dans les
mémoires des amateurs de foot an en
france c'est dire aussi les cimes que
nous avons par rapport à votre
jeu
je pense que ces dialogues avec vous est
l'occasion peut-être de revenir sur un
certain nombre de points qui suscitent
des incompréhensions des deux côtés de
la manche et je me permets d'en aborder
un
directement qui est la question la
billetterie papier vous savez que depuis
quelques jours ça donne lieu à un
certain nombre de débats est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire nous expliquer
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui est à
l'origine de la demande de la part alors
non pas de la ville bien entendu mais du
club de liverpool d'avoir des
billet papier et est ce que c'est une
demande que vous faites de manière
régulière c'est à dire à chaque match
s'il ya une
entrée une vérification par des billets
papier non pas des billets électroniques
a
donc je vais répondre à votre question
parce que vous m'avez posé mais pour moi
là
la vraie question c'est l'utilisation de
cette question des billets pour ensuite
créer
une fausse version des faits donc en ce
qui concerne les billets
les fans de liverpool vont de nombreux
matches de foot à l'extérieur
il n'y a jamais eu de problème avec les
billets nulle part ailleurs pour moi le
problème c'est que certains des
scanneurs n'acceptait pas des billets
valides il est rejeté et cela est
une accumulation dans les files
d'attentes
mais pour moi c'est aussi un moyen qui a
été utilisée pour ans pour se servir des
fans de liverpool comme un bouc
émissaire
[Musique]
on sait que les
du côté du real madrid s'était des
tickets électroniques étaient utilisés
pourtant il ya aussi eu des problèmes
donc le problème d'organisation ne
venait pas des billets ou des
accusations reposent contraint dé san
c'était en fait avant tout à partir de
la sortie des stations de métro que les
choses ont commencé à dégénérer
je sais que
et donc monsieur darmanin et madame un
oud avec 15 terrains ont
ils ont pillé une version qui pour moi
est fausse
de 30000 à 40000
faux billets et je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui a été qui sert le les
autorités françaises
et ce n'est pas la première fois ça
s'est aussi déjà passé après le match de
gilles perrault qu'on utilise des fans
comme boucs émissaires alors qu'un
indice paulo il y avait eu 97 morts donc
c'est vraiment un sujet sensible
et donc je crois que cette idée de
reporter la faute sur les fans a été
utilisée dès le début en utilisant des
écrans les images pour rejeter la faute
sur eux
et pourtant les femmes sont arrivées
avec trois heures d' avance et donc si
cela n'est pas suffisant je ne sais pas
combien de temps la vente il faut que
les écoles est enfin là quel est le
public arrive pour que les choses se
passent bien
et ensuite il ya aussi la question des
fans sans ticket qui a aussi était
utilisée et là encore je pense que c'est
de fausses accusations
et tout ce que dit monsieur tarn ain a
en fait n'est basée sur aucune preuve il
n'y a aucune preuve de ses fans des 48
500 tickets
ça fait partie des points soyez en sûr
que nous sommes en train de regarder
avec beaucoup d'attention nous avons eu
des auditions toute la journée ce matin
avec le préfet de policé cet après midi
avec les responsables de la fédération
française de foot de football
l'intention du sénat et bien sûr de
mettre à plat tous les
dysfonctionnements qui ont eu lieu et de
d'identifier les responsabilités des uns
et des autres ne l'ayez de doute sur
notre volonté de
bien faire la lumière sur l'ensemble des
dysfonctionnements qui ont eu lieu avec
les éléments qui sont les nôtres on
chanterait pas payer la moindre
ambiguïté là-dessus le sens de ma
question n'était pas de mettre l'accent
sur tel ou tel problème c'était de lever
certaines incompréhensions qui peuvent
naître des deux côtés de deux de la
manche et c'est vrai que
la censure la cité parce que la question
de la version deby billet papier
interroge un peu de notre côté c'est
pour ça que je me permettais de vous
repos de vous poser la question c'est à
dire est pourquoi il ya cette demande de
billets papier du côté de deux livres
que je crois que madrid a fait aussi des
demandes mais en moins grand nombre pour
être très transparent sur ce que nous
avons fait et peut-être pour bien
préciser aussi que nous comprenions ce
souci de compréhension que n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté
c'est vrai que c'est une pratique que
nous ne connaissons pas forcément côté
français c'est pour ça que que de
nombreux supporters se déplacent alors
même qu'ils n'ont pas de billets pour
aller voir le match qui se déplace à
l'étranger c'est quelque chose qui
intervient de manière régulière puisque
vous pourriez nous préciser est-ce que
de manière régulière quand le club de
liverpool joue à l'étranger que ce soit
en finale ou dans les
dents les matches qualificatifs
est-ce que de manière régulière il ya
comme ça des déplacements massifs de
supporters même quand ils n'ont pas de
billet
merci pour avoir clarifié votre question
je crois qu'il faudrait vraiment posé la
question au club de foot de liverpool
directement savoir pour comprendre
pourquoi ils ont demandé des tickets
papier
mais en tout cas si
le problème vient de ses papilles de ses
billets papier pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
donné au club de liverpool le choix
d'avoir ses papiers ces billets papier
plutôt que des billets électroniques
en tout cas si mme culte il semble que
ces billets papier soit autorisé donc
c'est pour ça que je comprends pas
vraiment le sens de votre question est
d'autant que les fans du real madrid qui
utilisaient des billets électroniques
ont eux aussi eu des problèmes pour
rentrer dans le stade puisque les
scanners aussi du côté de madrid ne
fonctionnent pas de la même manière
qu'ils n'ont pas fonctionné du côté de
liverpool
je crois que les choses auraient été
encore est ce que les choses auraient
été plus chaotique
si les fans de madrid avait pas eu de
billet électronique je sais pas c'est
difficile d'y répondre
c'est très facile d'aller à londres en
fait vous voyez ça prend une heure
trente on passe par le tunnel sous la
manche donc jusqu'à paris et c'est ce
qu'ont fait les fans de liverpool
les gens sont allés en france
avoir du tout l'intention de rentrer
dans le stade de france il voulait
profiter de l'atmosphère
il y avait la fan zone formidable qui
avait été mise en place avec des
dizaines de milliers de fans de
liverpool des supporters vraiment ce
sont extrêmement bien comportée qu'ils
ont c'est la fed qui se sont amusés qui
ont profité de l'événement
et
nous
en fait ce qu'ils pouvaient pas aller au
stade
ils ont regardé sur les écrans géants
alors si les autorités françaises où les
autorités du football ne voulait pas que
ses fans
voyage
en fait moi je pense que tout le monde a
le droit de se déplacer et d'aller
profiter de l'atmosphère à l'extérieur
du stade
et simplement aussi parce que
ils pensaient être les bienvenues en
fait voilà elle voulait profiter du sens
de l'hospitalité du peuple français et
c'est une bonne chose
donc
je n'accuse absolument personne n'est ce
pas mais il est vrai que dans certains
cas
et bien les supporters de liverpool qui
n'avait pas de tickets ont été un peu
trompé en fait le fait qu'on dise qu'il
essayait d'entrer quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est simplement faux enfin quarante
mille personnes où est-ce qu'ils ont
disparu parce qu'elles sont disparus ces
quarante mille personnes se sont
évanouies comme ça dans le métro juste
après le coup d'envoi moi ça
m'intéresserait de savoir
alors quelle est la méthode utilisée
pour obtenir ces chiffres aussi
concernant les faux billets
alors c'est quelqu'un qu'on a faits au
dos d'un paquet de cigarettes c'est ça
monsieur le maire sur le
la question d'aider des billets pour
être parfaitement papier pour être très
précis
il nous a été dit que l' usage dans la
compétition était d'utiliser les des
billets électroniques
que pour la finale
les espagnols avait effectivement
demandé un certain nombre de billets
papier dans un nombre assez faible
destiné 6000 exactement destiné à usage
interne j'allais presque dire du club
qui a qui les a attribuées à des invités
et l'autre par le club de liverpool a
demandé un un grand nombre de billets et
c'est à partir de là qu'il a été
constaté que un défaut en réalité ont
été réalisés et une enquête en cours sur
cette affaire là enquête judiciaire en
cours pour essayer de déterminer qui a
participé à cela comment cela a été fait
et c'est parfaitement normal
la question conseils qu'on a posés à la
fédération française de football mais en
réalité c'est un lieu est farc il faut
la dépose de l'imposer c'est
pourquoi avoir dérogé pour les deux
clubs il n'y a pas de discussion
possible pourquoi avoir déroger au
principe du billet électronique pour la
finale c'est une question sur laquelle
qu'on se pose parce que bon c'est pas le
seul problème loin de larsson bien
d'accord mais c'est une question que
l'on se pose moi j'aurais voulu monsieur
le maire que vous puissiez nous décrire
l'ambiance qui étaient autour de vous
lorsque vous êtes à vous êtes approché
de l'entrée du stade on nous dit que on
vous a demandé de monter par dessus les
grilles pour rentrer dans le stade ça
nous paraît absolument effrayant
et
on voudrait essayer de comprendre s'il y
avait effectivement beaucoup de monde
avec une pression très forte ou s'il y
avait peut-être moins de monde mais en
revanche un climat extrêmement violent
est ce que vous nous décrire cela s'il
vous plaît
bien
[Musique]
oui alors tout d'abord j'aimerais vous
nous expliquer les clarifier
ce point quand on m'a demandé de
d'escalader la grille je vais vous le
faire dans un instant alors tout d'abord
j'aimerais revenir à la première partie
de la question que vous m'avez posée à
savoir les tic et les billets
moi
je dois
avant tout reposer la question aux
autorités françaises et à l'uefa
et leur demander et bien s'il y avait un
problème
avec l'idée de fournir des billets
papier aux supporters de liverpool si
c'était un problème a bien pourquoi est
ce qu'on l'a fait alors s'il y avait un
problème avec les scanners avec les skis
ou chimiques ou autre je crois qu'on a
entendu que 66% des problèmes
donc les tentatives d'entrée avec un
faux billets
c'était des tentatives par des
supporters de liverpool et je suis
convaincu que sur ses 66% il y avait des
vrais billets qui ont été rejetées par
les appareils
mais quoi qu'il en soit 66%
alors est ce que c'est le chiffre exact
je ne suis pas sûr en tout cas si
c'était le chiffre exact ça veut dire
qu'il y à 44 %
de ces faux billets
qui étaient en fait des billets
électroniques du real madrid
alors je veux bien entendu il semblerait
qu'il y ait plus de billets rejetée pour
les supporters de liverpool que ceux de
madrid mais ça veut quand même dire que
un grand nombre de billets électroniques
de liverpool
ont été ou n'aurait pas été rejetée
avant et ça ça fait tout c'est que en
fait tous ces problèmes donc cette
question des billets en fait une
tentative de la part des autorités de ne
pas vraiment essayer de comprendre les
raisons fondamentales des problèmes
autour du stade pour ce qui est de mon
cas personnel
comme des milliers d'autres supporters
lorsque nous sommes sortis de la station
de métro
nous avons marché tout droit il ya 20 ce
grand boulevard
et ensuite on a rêvé sur la place en
tournée vers la gauche pour arriver sur
la place et pour y parvenir il y avait
une route et un
une barrière pour les piétons et un
trottoir et il y avait des fans sur la
partie piétonne et aussi des gens sur la
partie goudronnée de la route d'accord
donc plusieurs centaines de mètres plus
loin
tout s'arrête
en fait c'est bloqué c'est bloqué par
des véhicules de police des camionnettes
de police
et il ya toute une ligne de gendarmes
avec leurs matraques la main qui sont
devant les camionnettes et e
il disait aux gens
de passer
par dessus
[Musique]
ces barrières en fait pour les piétons
qui était assez haute
en fait donc pour arriver sur la partie
piétonne en fait et alors que les gens
passaient par-dessus en fait il fallait
déposer ses effets personnels et
utiliser la rambarde pour pouvoir
grimper par dessus et c'est en faisant
sa
queue il ya eu des pickpockets qui en
ont profité et c'est ce qui m'est arrivé
à moi
et là c'était pas pour entrer dans le
stade en fait un là je pense qu'il ya
une incompréhension malentendu
mois
des agents de police m'ont aidé à
parvenir jusqu'aux stades obtenir un
billet de remplacement c'est voilà c'est
ce qui m'est arrivé à moi
ce
michel ça va
merci messieurs les présidents monsieur
le maire
tout d'abord comme beaucoup de mes
collègues nous regrettons
les propos qui ont été tenus à l'égard
de votre ville et de ses habitants
suite aux événements qui se sont
déroulés donc le soir de cette finale
nous regrettons aussi les actes de
délinquance et d'agressions qui se sont
déroulées
aux entrées mais aussi au sortir
de ce match liverpool real de madrid
moi je voudrais avoir votre avis sur
les propos qu'a tenu le ministre de
l'intérieur
alors je vais le j'ai repris mot pour
mot les propos qu'il a tenus devant les
sénateurs
nous nous sommes attendus avec liverpool
a des problèmes
on penser que les problème viendrait du
boulou guen d'hooliganisme et des
mouvements de foule violent
il n'est pas venu de là
il est venu de faux billets et c'est
sans doute une explication de ce qui
s'est passé samedi soir à
écouter les ministres de l'intérieur
les débordements et les actes de
délinquance qui se sont déroulés autour
du stade étaient dues à la présence de
support de milliers de supporters de
liverpool qui n'avaient pas de billets
ou qu'il y avait des faux billets
alors comme vous monsieur le maire
depuis le début de ces auditions nous
essayons avec le président les
présidents la faune et buffet
d'avoir toute la transparence sur les
chiffres qui sont annoncés notamment sur
les 30 à 40000 spectateurs
plusieurs fois j'ai interrogées soit le
ministre les ministres soit monsieur le
préfet soit les gens de la fédération
française de foot concernant les fameux
30000 à 40000 sans billet ou avec faux
billets et c'est un point important car
des images
de télévisions à 21h
démontre le stade de france
et là c'est 30 à 40 me donc complètement
disparu nous avons la sncf a fait des
communiqués pour expliquer qu'il n'y
avait pas eu un surplus de voix yeux de
voyageurs
après 21h et de c'est vrai que
soyez en sûr du côté du sénat la
question reste entière
2e 2e point que je voulais voir avec
vous c'est quelle est la réaction du
maire de liverpool et les habitants de
liverpool des anglais sur le fait comme
vous l'avez dit au début de votre
intervention
avoir l'impression que on essaye de
focaliser la responsabilité sur la
présence nombreuse de supporters anglais
en faisant abstraction des actes de
délinquance
et d'agressions qui lui ont eu qu il y a
eu qui se sont tenues donc autour du
stade quel est votre la réaction
aujourd'hui du supporters et du maire de
liverpool
merci monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
maire
merci beaucoup
je vais
répondre en deux parties alors tout
d'abord
[Musique]
pour revenir sur le témoignage fait par
monsieur le ministre monsieur darmanin
il s'attendait à des problèmes
il s'attendait à ce que des hooligans
soit là
et
je peux vous assurer que s'il y avait eu
un match à wembley il y aura pas eu
beaucoup de fans de liverpool qui serait
allé
alors
j'ai une certaine façon ou à de nombreux
égards
quelque chose qui explique peut-être la
façon dont les policiers ont
abordé ce match peut-être que ça
explique aussi certains problèmes qu'on
a constatée
moi j'ai
vu
des policiers qui en fait d'une certaine
façon chercher des problèmes ne trouvez
pas se regrouper
et menacé plusieurs personnes avec leurs
matraques
donc si on avait vraiment
des incidents
graves
qui nécessitent de recourir à la force
de la police est bien là on aurait des
images il ya toutes sortes de façons
d'avoir ce genre de vidéos de nos jours
les gens ils ont des téléphones vidéo
des téléphones portables et vous pourrez
avoir donc ce genre de preuve ou d'image
et je crois que monsieur darmana a
essayé peut-être de tromper non
seulement le public français mais aussi
les médias dans le monde entier moi dans
mon pays je sais que les responsables
politiques aiment bien parfois
voir un peu la vérité à leur façon notre
premier ministre d'ailleurs mais cela
n'excuse en aucun cas les autorités
françaises
qui ont conçu une campagne pour faire
reporter la faute sur d'autres et
trouver
des boucs émissaires et donc les fans de
liverpool et bien c'est une excuse à ses
pratiques finalement pour
dévier l'attention de la mauvaise
préparation
alors
moi j'ai parlé avec
et analystes sotchi au
rif au vin
moi je me suis rendu plusieurs fois en
france et n'ai jamais vu une telle est l
échec en matière d'ordre public et
d'organisation policière toutes les fois
juste suis rendue en france pour des
matchs
en ce qui concerne les billets et il
faut billet je n'ai aucun doute que
il y aurait toujours un certain nombre
de faux billets
dans les grands événements sportifs à
travers le monde
mais en tout cas même ce chiffre de 40
milles
clickair a été un peu ridiculisé
véritablement
et ensuite les autorités françaises ont
annoncé comme jfe 2500 faux tickets
seulement alors je ne sais pas si c'est
quand même un grand nombre par rapport
aux capacités à la capacité du stade de
france en tout cas ce que je sais c'est
que c'est un nombre bien inférieur
à ce qui était annoncé initialement de
quarante mille tickets
et donc ce n'est absolument pas vrai
c'est même ridicule de dire qu'il y
avait un aussi grand nombre
et si la situation n'était pas si
sérieuse moi je vive un véritablement
en tout cas il ya vraiment eu un
problème d'organisation un problème de
communication
et heureusement cela a été contré par
l'exemplaire vraiment exceptionnelle et
exemplaire des fans de liverpool
certains d'entre eux étant arrivés plus
de trois heures à l avance au stade
et les supporteurs se sont entraidés les
uns les autres
et ont assuré eux mêmes en quelque sorte
l'ordre à l'extérieur
du stade
donc l'accusation qui consiste à dire
que l'on peut utiliser des gaz
lacrymogènes
pour ramener l'ordre
fausse aussi enfin pour moi ce n'est pas
un moyen en fait de règles de ramener
l'ordre et plutôt en fait un moyen de
disperser les gens dans toutes les
directions et cela peut provoquer
d'ailleurs des blessures graves
il n'y avait donc aucun contrôle et les
styles et les services policiers sont
complètement effondrés
merci merci monsieur le maire je vais
donner la parole à notre collègue
sénatrice madame jacqueline eustache
brinio
merci monsieur le président tout d'abord
monsieur le maire je voudrais m'associer
évidemment aux propos des deux
présidents le président mme buffet le
président la fin sur le fait que nous
regrettions vivement que tout ce fiasco
français soient expliquées par nos
ministres par le comportement des
anglais moi j'en suis très attristé
c'est un pays que j'adore l'angleterre
est vraiment je suis vraiment triste à
l'idée que on ait pu tout mettre sur le
dos des supporteurs anglais deux choses
monsieur le maire l'angleterre a prouvé
à la france que vous savez anticiper des
grands événements puisque quelques jours
après vous avez organisé le jubilé avec
des milliers et des milliers et des
milliers d'anglais qui ont participé à
des fêtes et qu'il n'y a eu aucun
incident donc la belle preuve de votre
comportement du respect et du bon
comportement des anglais vous l'avez
prouvé trois jours après à nos ministres
qui ne veulent pas assumer leur fiasco
donc ça je voulais le dire vous avez
vous avez dit une phrase qui m'a
extrêmement peiné c'est que vous avez
dit au tout début de vos propos que
votre journée de raids samedi s'était
transformé en cauchemar comment ne pas
être touché par cette phrase quand on
vient effectivement
préparer enfin tout cas soutenir son
équipe c'est quelque chose qui
m'attriste qui m'a beaucoup attristé
dans leurs propos je veux dire vous avez
bien fait d'assister sur les fans zone
parce que moi j'étais à paris vendredi
samedi il y avait beaucoup de supporters
anglais espagnol qui avait effectivement
à paris un très très bon climat on va
aller sur les champs-elysées gens qui se
prennent en photo il y avait aucun
problème et il n'y a eu aucun problème
dans les fan zone paris aucun il faut le
signaler ce qui veut dire que quand même
les supporters anglais espagnol et
français qui était avec vous savent se
comporter correctement moi je voudrais
avoir savoir monsieur le maire vous nous
avez expliqué votre expérience
personnelle le fait qu'on vous a demandé
de passer par dessus les grilles que
vous n'avez pas fait attention que
autour de vous il y avait effectivement
des délinquants à des gens qu'ils
étaient prêts à tous vous volez et que
malheureusement vous avez été victimes
de ces vols est-ce que parmi les
supporteurs qui vous ont croisé qui vous
ont qui ont témoigné un certain josé est
ce que vous avez senti senti ou ressenti
ce sentiment
d'insécurité autour du stade de france
par ces hordes de délinquants qui
attendait les supporters pour les
dépouiller est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez ressenti vous avez
vu et est ce que beaucoup de supporters
qui ont été victimes vous ont témoigné
un certain nombre de faits une semaine
en tout cas sachez que nous sommes
nombreux à soutenir votre démarche et
nous sommes très nombreux à comprendre
ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
mais c'est pas que madame
merci
moi je m'étais rendu en france avec de
grandes attentes
je voulais vraiment voir un spectacle
mais finalement j'étais trop désespéré
pour aller prendre aller m'asseoir et
dans le stade donc j'ai regardé
l'événement depuis l'extérieur
[Musique]
ils ont su l'exprimer préoccupations de
à de grands à de nombreux invités
importants ou à des personnes à
l'extérieur
je crois que je vais tout à fait raison
madame
ce qu'il ya eu bien sûr de nombreuses
célébrations très joyeuse des
démonstrations de camaraderie
et de personnes qui vraiment ont aimé le
moment avant le match mais les choses
ont dégénéré et des choses dégénèrent et
et que l'on s'approchait du stade
et cela était vraiment à cause du manque
de présence policière ou à l'art ensuite
intervention policière trop musclé
il pour remettre les choses dans leur
contexte
j'étais aussi présent au match de 2014
de lille contre everton et il ya eu les
mêmes tactiques qui étaient utilisés par
la police à l'époque
et honnêtement ce n'est pas le genre de
tactique auquel les britanniques sont
habitués une des choses que nous faisons
bien royaume uni c'est qu'on a
l'habitude de faire la queue
et généralement les gens respectent en
quelque sorte le protocole les règles
non écrites de la file d'attenté et
c'est exactement ce qu'il s'est passé
aussi aux alentours du stade de france
les gens faisaient la queue veut pas
seulement
mais aucune information n'a été donnée
aux fans pour leur expliquer combien de
temps il leur faudrait il faudrait
attendre pour rentrer dans le stade
aussi il n'avait pas vraiment de
stadiers qui était président pour bien
orienter les gens vers la bonne files
d'attentes par rapport aux tourniquets
qu'il devait utiliser
il n'y avait pas non plus de contrôle
près limitèrent préliminaire pardon des
des billets
est donc pour moi vraiment l'expérience
a été totalement décevant tu
ne vas pas complètement entacher ce que
je pense de la france moi je vais en
vacances en france
souvent et je me suis toujours senti
très bien accueilli toutefois si c'était
votre première expérience de la france
les systèmes votre première rencontre
avec la police française
alors je ne suis vraiment pas sûr que
vous aimeriez retourner en france
et c'est pour ça qu'il est important
c'est que la vérité émerge vraiment et
non pas les mensonges qui sont relayés
par des personnes qui ont pourtant une
position de pouvoir et qui devrait se
comporter différemment
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faudrait
vraiment qu'il y ait une enquête
indépendante qui fasse toute la lumière
sur ce qui s'est passé et j'espère que
le vous au sénat vous pourriez vraiment
analyser la question dans son ensemble
et en tirer des enseignements
car je sais qu'il ya eu d'autres jeux
par exemple d'autres matches par exemple
il ya un match france danemark juste la
semaine suivante et une fois encore
certaines personnes ont eu des
difficultés à rentrer dans le stade donc
il me semble
que des entraînements n'ont pas encore
été tirés
et les problèmes inhérents intrinsèque à
l'organisation n'ont pas encore été
analysés
oui jean jacques lozach et ensuite guy
benarroch oui messieurs les présidents
monsieur le maire bon notre état
d'esprit bien évidemment ça n'est
surtout pas de montrer du doigt les les
supporters de liverpool mais de savoir
très précisément ce qui s'est passé la
soirée du du 28 mai dans mes dents dans
certaines circonstances les mots
prennent
un sens un intérêt tout à fait
particulier je veux dire par là que à ce
stade
tout le monde exprime des regrets ce
matin le préfet de police a exprimé ses
regrets cet après midi les représentants
de la fédération française de football
ont exprimé des regrets par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé
mais personne n'a encore exprimé des
excuses
mais je voudrais savoir monsieur le
maire si vous attendez des excuses de la
part des autorités publiques françaises
comme certains l'ont sollicité
deuxièmement pardonner mans qu'on n'a
plus le maire avec nous
deuxièmement pardonnez mon insistance
mais je voudrais revenir sur la nature
de la billetterie et savoir si le club
de liverpool le club d être vérifiée kit
entendre
qu'ils seraient pleinement acceptée
je crois toutefois qu'une des excuses
complètes sont nécessaires mais pas
seulement de la part des autorités
françaises
le f a aussi à une grande responsabilité
ici
et j'ai parlé précédemment d'une enquête
supposément indépendante si cette
enquête vraiment rempli les objectifs
qu'ils devraient remplir et bien et doit
avoir là une représentation des deux
clubs de football
et aussi des personnes qui ont vécu les
événements depuis de l'extérieur
[Musique]
se sont vraiment ces expériences qui
peuvent orienter l'enquète et permettre
ensuite d'en tirer des enseignements
tirés des enseignements de cette débâcle
il ya eu lieu à l'extérieur du stade de
france
et aussi de comprendre comment
protéger à l'avenir les événements
sportifs et les supporteurs pour qu'ils
ne se retrouvent pas dans la situation
dans laquelle se sont retrouvés les fans
de liverpool ce soir là
et peut-être aussi les fans de du rien
de matri même si moi je n'étais pas de
leur côté
il ya eu beaucoup de spéculations
et beaucoup de choses ont été dites en
fait par des personnes qui pourtant ne
comprennent pas la situation parce
qu'ils ne l'ont pas vécue mais croyez
moi c'était vraiment situation difficile
et pour une personne de mon âge qui a
déjà vécu des expériences traumatisantes
par le passé lors de matches de football
en angleterre
il pas cela vraiment réveil de très
mauvais souvenirs
et je détesterais que d'autres fans
doivent vivre ce que les fans de
liverpool ont déjà vécu
donc je ne veux pas dire les conclusions
devraient déjà être atteinte avant que
l'enquêté ne soit menée
mais je crois que la proportionnalité
des responsabilités
ne doit pas simplement tombé sur la
police et les organisateurs il faut
aussi qu'il lui est sain l'uefa doit
aussi répondre à des questions
merci messieurs merci nous permettait on
va regrouper plusieurs questions comme
ça vous pourrez répondre globalement et
à chacun dont jean jacques lozach qui
n'avait pas fini de poser sa question
c'est est pas noir que j'avais oublié il
m'en excuse je l'espère et guy laroche
oui j'étais en train de poser une
question sur la nature de la billetterie
pour savoir si le club de liverpool le
club des rays v systématique
systématiser ou non le recours à la
billetterie électronique pour les
matches qui se déroule en deux fils dans
le cadre de la première ligue et si le
parquet la vie de liverpool entendez ou
pas ouvrir une enquête au sujet de cette
fraude à la billetterie enfin on le sait
à l'instar des supporters madrilènes des
supporters anglais s'estimant victimes
d'infractions peuvent désormais déposer
plainte
assistés de policiers français dépêchés
sur place à votre connaissance monsieur
le maire
y at il beaucoup de britanniques y ont à
ce stade exercer ce droit
stéphane pieds noirs pour la suite merci
monsieur le président seul maire
je compatis évidemment aux expressions
précédente sur cette soirée malheureuse
qui a conduit un certain nombre de
supporters et d'anglais tout court à
découvrir parfois la france sur sous cet
angle là
j'avais des questions qui s'adresse à la
fois ouvert et j'ai envie de dire aux
supporters de liverpool que vous êtes
est en lien avec le club de liverpool
lune la première question c'est sur le
classement de cette rencontre en terme
de deux niveaux de risques on a entendu
l'auteur la fédération qui plaçait à peu
près ce match au même niveau de risques
que la finale la coupe de france quel
est votre point de vue sur une finale de
ligue des champions entre deux clubs
forcément enfin non c'est pas le cas
toujours mais de pays différents quelles
sont les relations entre les clubs de
livres historiques entre les clubs de
liverpool ide et du real de madrid pour
s'attendre éventuellement à des à des
tensions la deuxième question c'est
concernant les informations compte tenu
de ces tensions éventuelles les
informations qui sont données aux
supporters qui font le déplacement à
ceux qui font le déplacement détenteur
ou non de billets pour rentrer dans le
stade sur bien les précautions à prendre
sur éventuellement les moyens de pour se
rendre au stade de france on sait qu'il
y avait une grève qui était annoncé sur
ligne de l'une des lignes de rer est ce
que des informations pratiques comme
celles là ont été données et puis
troisième question je disais tout à
l'heure le club de les clubs anglais
d'une manière générale ont l'habitude et
ont eu un passé suffisamment dense en
terme de hooliganisme si je puis dire
pour prendre des mesures préventives et
et a posteriori lorsque des incidences
se déroulent au tour de stade ou dans
les stades que pensez-vous de de la non
réquisition des images vidéo de
surveillance autour du stade de
surveillance
vidéo protection autour du stade de
france qui on est et qui n'ont pas été
réquisitionnée et qui donc dans un délai
de sept jours me semble-t-il ont été
automatiquement écrasé donc ne sont plus
disponibles pour faire une enquête
approfondie en tout cas sur le notamment
sur le nombre de présents autour du
stade de france je remercie et enfin
dernière question monsieur le maire par
guy benarroch
le sénateur j'entendais oui oui je vous
entends bien allez-y je m'excuse
monsieur le maire de l'absence d'image
il ya une paresse de marc de mon
ordinateur je vous parle de marseille
qui est au même titre que liverpool une
grande ville du football européen et
vous avez déjà en tout cas le soutien
de beaucoup de supporters de l'olympique
de marseille et de l'om je tenais à vous
le dire la question porte sur votre vécu
votre témoignagnes celui vous avez pu
recueillir l'éventuelle mans de celles
d'autres supporteurs de liverpool qui
vous en en parler après en tant que
maire de cette ville une grande partie
de l'explication de l'utilisation
des gaz lacrymogènes vis-à-vis de
supporteurs anglais qui était pourtant
calme et qui avaient leur billet tiens
au fait qu' il y aurait eu risque moment
donné par la papal le cheminement vous
avez
suivi il y aurait eu risque à un moment
donné d'écrasement parce que des traces
moins de supporteurs avec donc de grave
danger pour leur santé ou pour leur vie
en raison justement
de là du fait que vous tous ces
supporteurs arrivés finalement par un
cheminement qui n'était pas forcément
bien prévu en fonction des grèves et
qu'ils arrivaient sur des contrôles où
il y avait beaucoup de problèmes avec
des faux billets ou des stylos qu'il
faut que ce départ est ce que certains
de vos administrés ou vous même avez
vous hâte retrouver proche de ces
endroits là s'ils étaient qui mettait en
péril la santé vital de ses supporteurs
au point que la police était obligée de
les laisser passer dans un premier temps
puis de dégager avec des gaz
lacrymogènes le sud goulot
d'étranglement suivant qui étaient les
tourniquets d'entrée au stade avez-vous
vous avez vous vu avez vous eu des
témoignages sur ces situations la
délicate merci
monsieur le maire on voulait se répondre
à ces trois séries de questions
merci beaucoup
je vais essayer de répondre aux
questions dans l'ordre dans lesquelles
elles m'ont été posées
à nouveau
on en revient la question des billets
des faux billets
alors ce sera l enquête de déterminer
quelle était la quantité de faux billets
mais je suis convaincu que le chiffre
sera bien bien inférieurs ou quarante
mille
annoncé par le ministère de l'intérieur
français et par la ministre des sports
il y aurait toujours défaut paix qui
toujours des gens qui essaieront
d'entrée lors d'un événement important
avec des faux billets ou d'une autre
façon
très clairement
et on l'a vu dans les vidéos dans les
images les gens qui ont si d'entrée
c'était des locaux c'était des français
il ya personne de l'autre côté
qui
accuse ces personnes
pour ce qui s'est passé elle n'aura pas
dû faire
ce qu'elles ont fait bien entendu mais
c'est pourquoi il faut des stadiers
c'est pourquoi il faut des forces de
l'ordre c'est pourquoi il faut une
organisation adéquate
et nouveau il semble que le gouvernement
français et 30,1 de
s'accrocher à sa version des faits pour
détourner l'attention du véritable
problème le problème fondamental à
savoir une organisation défaillante eh
les gars à l'extérieur du stade
et moi
en fait
les policiers avaient l'air davantage
prêts à réagir à des émeutes plutôt qu'à
un match de foot
et
[Musique]
alors j'espère avoir bien compris la
question concernant le hooliganisme des
fans anglais
je crois que à nouveau c'est un écran de
fumée
bien entendu il y a eu des cas dans le
passé
dans la plupart des fédérations
nationales de foot
on a eu des exemples de hooliganisme
mais ce n'est pas une maladie anglaise
d'ailleurs si on regarde ce qu'il se
passe en première ligue
vous verrez bien qu'il y a moins deux
personnes arrêtées que n'importe où
ailleurs dans le monde dans des ligues
comparables les gens ne vont pas au
match de foot pour se comporter comme
des hooligans hills et vaut pour
soutenir leur équipe de foot parce
qu'ils sont passionnés par ce que ce
sont des fans
et ils sont fans de leur équipe de foot
mais il est très rare que cela se
traduise par du hooliganisme à grande
échelle
donc
ses antécédents de hooliganisme
c'est aussi une nouvelle fois une façon
de détourner l'attention
alors est-ce que les gens étaient au
courant de la grève
oui
alors
en grande partie et c'est la raison pour
laquelle beaucoup d'entre eux sont
arrivés bien en avance
savez des fans qui vont au stade de foot
trois heures avant le coup d'envoi c'est
rare
donc ça vous montre à quel point les
supporters avaient envie de voir
ce match fantastique
donc les gens ils sont allés bien en
avance
et les grilles ont été fermées alors que
des gens avaient encore des billets
tout à fait légaux
et on leur a demandé d'aller vers
d'autres appareils
et je pense que
ce mythe des faux tickets
eh bien on
verra que c'était surtout dû au fait que
les scanners n'étaient pas allés bon
fait il ne pouvait pas lire
les bons billets les gens n'ont pas pu
entrer parce que il ya eu tout ce genre
de problème que je viens de mentionner
mais à nouveau ce n'est pas à moi
d'en tirer les conclusions
vous savez
alors il ya sept joueurs de liverpool
qui a donné le billet à son ami
et il a essayé de passer son billet il a
été rejeté par la machine
donc voilà
est vraiment pour moi et ça c'était un
choc parce que c'est la première fois
que j'entends cet argument c'est le fait
que les vidéos de la vidéosurveillance
autour du stade ont été détruites
alors ça c'est vraiment inquiétant
et je ne peux vous pas du tout
comprendre pourquoi
alors que cet événement
est
tout aussi important est alors
qu'il faut quand même savoir ce qui
s'est passé il est important de
recueillir l'ensemble des preuves et si
c'est vrai que ces preuves vidéo de
vidéosurveillance ont été
écrasés si les images ont été écrasés et
bien ça montre très clairement qu'il y a
un problème
il ya un vrai problème avec ce qu'on
aurait pu voir sur ces images de
vidéosurveillance et je suis
véritablement choqué pour être honnête
et monsieur le sénateur à la fin qui a
parlé de marseille alors moi je suis
allé beaucoup de fois à marseille
nous
l'accueil très volontiers et les
supporters de marseille qui soit
également de supporters de liverpool et
je dois vous dire que à chaque fois que
je suis chez moi à liverpool
les gens en fait ils m'arrêtent dans la
rue et ils m'expliquent ce qui leur est
arrivé d'ailleurs même une demi heure
avant de venir ici j'ai parlé à
quelqu'un à l'extérieur du bâtiment qui
s'était fait voler ses effets de même
que ses amis et ils étaient horrifiés
par ce qu'il avait vécu et les exemples
sont nombreux
pour ce qui est de
l' usage
de gaz lacrymogènes de gaz poivré
son distinction
eh bien j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit le
chef de police il a dit qu'il était
nécessaire d'employer les gaz
lacrymogènes pour faire en sorte que les
gens s'éloignent des grilles parce qu'il
y avait le risque qu'elles soient
écrasés
mais à nouveau le recours aux gaz
lacrymogènes
sans distinction
pour disperser les gens c'est pas comme
ça qu'on contrôler les foules au
contraire on perd le contrôle de la
foule parce que les gens sont aspergés
de gaz
ils ont du mal à respirer
et
ça montre bien selon moi que
il y a eu une incompréhension
alors moi j'ai discuté avec un chef de
la police en angleterre et il m'a dit
qu'il n'avait jamais rien vu de tel dans
toute sa carrière jamais rien vu d'aussi
grave
donc là aussi il ya quand même des
questions à poser il faut comprendre
aller au fond des choses et voir comment
il se fait que les choses se soient
aggravées aussi rapidement et pourquoi
les gendarmes pensaient qu'il serait
confronté à des gros problème du
hooliganisme
c'est qu'il ya un problème en haut de
l'échelle non parce que la grande grande
majorité des supporters de liverpool ils
sont allés au stade pour faire la fête
pour célébrer une saison de foot
formidable pour célébrer un entraîneur
formidable
c'est tout
merci monsieur le maire je compte il n'y
a plus de question de notre côté je
voulais et je le fais bien sûr au nom de
l'ensemble des des sénateurs de la
commission des lois et ceux de la
commission de la culture vous remercier
très sincèrement de de votre
participation cet après midi à nos
traditions c'était pour nous important
de d'échanger avec vous
d'abord dans le travail de recherche de
la vérité que nous menons depuis
plusieurs jours et je le redis mais
c'est important de redire vous pouvez
compter sur nous pour que l'ensemble des
faits soient
présentés tels qu'ils ont vraiment eu
lieu et que la nature des incidents dont
ont été victimes un certain nombre de
personnes samedi au stade de france est
régulièrement des supporters de
liverpool la nature ces incidents soient
vraiment qu'on
soit explicité et compris de tous et
puis bien sûr cet échange était aussi
pour nous l'occasion de
de vous témoigner notre notre sympathie
et notre amitié de vous redire toute
estime que nous avons pour le club de
liverpool et pour votre ville et
regretter comme chacun de ceux et celles
qui ont pris la parole cet après midi
l'onf et regrettait bien sûr les
événements qui se sont déroulés devant
le stade de france lors de la finale de
la champion s league il était important
pour nous de vous le dire et de de vous
entendre pour que vous nous fassiez part
aussi de votre témoignage donc merci
monsieur le maire je sais pas si le
président veut dire quelque chose
je m'associe bien sûr aux propos du
président la faune je voudrais je ne
veux pas terminer cette audition sans
vous dire que les informations que nous
avons obtenues cet après-midi sur les
images vidéo
nous interpelle et que donc nous allons
immédiatement vérifier la réalité de la
situation
car s'il advenait
que ces images n'ait pas été conservée
en tous les cas qu'on en n'ait pas
demandé la conservation
cela poserait un grave problème de notre
point de vue donc nous allons faire en
toute hypothèse merci beaucoup merci à
vous peut-être que nous reviendrons vers
vous peut-être pour les supporter
liverpool éventuellement
ici
si monsieur le maire merci beaucoup nos
matches
explique guérin est bien placé